[Musique]
utilise un sortilège
alors quoi on épluche des bouquins pour
déjouer le sortilège mémoire d'homme ne
vous inquiétez pas ne nous feront pas de
mal lors dans son temps citrouille un
coût de 6 6 oui enfin beaucoup c'est une
notion purement subjective de mon point
de vue il est ce qu'il faut d'horloge a
fait pas attention il y en a une qui
tourne pas rond là
tarou à rocher fichu et le cliquet ne va
pas tarder à lâcher bonjour tu es lewis
je présume
le voyage n'a plus cette vie souhaité ma
voisine d'à côté madame florence
zimmermann je me réjouis de constater
que tu n'as pas hérité de la tête
démesurément volumineuse de ton oncle
dixit la femme qui ressemble à un coton
tige au regarde la gigantesque dette est
en colère quel prodige
le squelette violette ou racornie viens
de parler ne fait pas attention à elle
elle se croit plus malin que moi parce
qu'elle a plus de diplômes
universitaires
non je ne crois plus maligne que toi car
je suis plus maligne que toi
[Musique]
l'alchimiste robben sort et se vit plus
on change le en or et ben c'était
vraiment très très très très très
mauvaise qu'elle fait catastrophique
arrête on dirait que tu lis le mode
d'emploi d'une tondeuse écoute ce n'est
pas ce que tu dit l'important c'est la
façon de le dire il n'y a pas d'autres
toits au monde de tout l'univers tu es
le seul c'est ça qui fait que ton style
de magie complètement unique personne
n'a le même dans toute la galaxie
alors les livres je peux te les prêter
l'essor je peux te les apprendre mais le
dernier petit pour cent il ne dépend que
de toi et si je veux trouver mon style
de magie qu'est ce que je dois faire
exactement il est en toi quelque part il
suffit de faire le vide et d'écouté
là on dirait plutôt que tu es au cabinet
[Musique]
le professeur joseph l
tu parles
[Musique]
terminus mais oui je suis ton oncle
johnattan tu es habillée en robe de
chambre
c'est un kimono nous y voilà notre petit
chez nous
tu es lewis je présume le voyage tu as
plus cette vieille chouette et ma
voisine
je me réjouis de constater que tu n'as
pas hérité de la tête démesurément
volumineuse de ton oncle miracle le
squelette violette ou racornie viens de
parler
tu verras cet endroit est tout à fait
surprenant tu peux aller visiter
il n'y a absolument aucun danger
c'est sans danger ce truc parce qu'il a
le ventre plein tu sais ce qu un mage
lewis mon âme sorcier je crois que comme
sorciers c'est un petit peu réducteur tu
veux dire que tu es un mage s'il te
plaît apprends moi ce peuple est
d'accord
comme tu voudras je peux te prêter les
bons livres d'apprendre les bonnes
formules mais le dernier petit pourcent
ne dépend que de toi
j'en veux pas du nabot bizarre tu crois
que j'en veux moi
coup de chance
tu as tout raconter à lewiston
ah bah non pas tout
diantre
l'ancien propriétaire de la maison et
images lui aussi il est très mal faisant
est très puissant il a laissé une
horloge cachés dans les murs on ne sait
pas à quoi elle sert à paraître
effrayantes
trois cours la dernière fois c'était 4
il se passera quoi quand ce ne sera plus
qu'un en tout cas rien de bon c'est sûr
nous devons détruire l'horloge
j'ai la chair de poule tu n'y arriveras
pas tout seul je peux t'aider
tu veux voir la vraie magie je vais te
montrer
décidément j'aime pas du citron
vous avez vu ça
[Musique]